في عام 1984 ، كانت المنافسة تغادر
حقبة الغرفة العملاقة للثلاجة ، حيث
ظهر شيء ماكنتوش ، وقد أحضرت
ماكنتوش إلى معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا ،
أتى رجال كبار السن وأقول لهم ما هو أنه يحتوي
على صور ،
كانت الخريطة تعيد تخيل ما
يمكن أن يكون الكمبيوتر هناك كان هناك ابتسامة  وجه
كان هناك روح الدعابة التي تم إنشاؤها بطريقة ما
مثل رجل الكهف الشريك الآنسة يمكنك
الذهاب واللعب بطريقة ما ،
إنها شفافة جدًا لتجربة
تجعلك تنعشك
ولم أفكر مطلقًا في أنني سأحصل على
مهنة كموسيقي أردت أن أفعل
كل شيء  أنا والطريقة الوحيدة التي
كانت ممكنة هي تناول الوجبات الخفيفة ، تخيل مدى
قوتها بالنسبة لمكتب الأطفال
وكانوا يكتشفون الأشياء
بأنفسهم ، فهذا يمحو جدران الفصل الدراسي
التي يمكن أن يقولوا أن هناك رؤية
وراءها ألهمت الناس للتفكير
فيما هو ممكن ولكن ذلك  جعل الناس يقومون
بعمل أفضل يبدو أنهم يتحدثون نفس
اللغة التي كنا نتحدث بها ، بدا
الأمر رائعًا وكان من الجيد أنه كان من
الطبيعي أن يكون جميع المصممين لدينا  نلاحظ أن
جميع صانعي الصور لن يذهبوا إلى نظام Mac بالنسبة
لي ، وهي أداة لإخراج أفكاري من
رأسي والتعاون مع الناس
لاستكشاف المجالات التي لم أستطع بخلاف ذلك ،
كنا نحاول استخدام هذا الجهاز
بطريقة استفزازية وجديدة حقًا و  لقد
كان رائعًا حقًا لم يكن أي شخص آخر
يفعل ذلك ،
هذا ما يبدو عليه الرواد مثل
كل شيء أفعله يمكن القيام به
بطريقة أكثر تشويقًا باستخدام مكتب Macintosh
وليس مثل هذا ، فأنت تعطينا
صندوق طلاء جديدًا وعلينا أن نصاب بالجنون.
لن نذهب للنوم ،
لن نذهب لتناول الطعام ، سنذهب ونلعب مع
هذا الشيء لأنه ملهم
الآن يستخدم الجميع هذه القطعة من
التكنولوجيا الرائعة في كل مكان ،
لم أكن أعتقد حقًا أنها ستكون
ديمقراطية عالمية حقًا
للإبداع ، فإن القوة العظيمة لأدوات
مثل Macintosh هي بالتحديد أنه
لا يمكنك التنبؤ بالمكان الذي سيذهبون إليه
مستقبل الإبداع ، إنه حقًا
يجمع الأشخاص معًا ويجمع
الأفكار معًا
ولم يكن لدى أي شخص أي فكرة 30 ye  منذ زمن
بعيد ، كيف سيكون العالم الآن أو
كيف سيتم استخدام هذه الأدوات ،
فهي مثيرة للاهتمام على وجه التحديد
لأنك لا تعرف كيف سيتم
استخدامها
غدًا وهذا هو جمال وقوة
Macintosh